hi I'm Becky I'm Katy we are trying
every hot breakfast item from Starbucks
we I just like throw a banana down my
throat just to be alive and then on the
weekend if I'm hungover then it's
definitely Starbucks I almost always eat
breakfast generally like I'll make an
egg bake or something they'll have or
sometimes make little egg cups I am very
familiar with and Starbucks breakfast I
always try to see make sure I move into
buildings with a Starbucks on the corner
that's a commitment as you play yeah
there is the classic oatmeal and we've
got we've got a little jacket we're
building our own mm-hmm building a
little oatmeal here we've got brown
sugar looks like I'm fruit nuts are you
allergic tonight no so should we go all
in that's a lot of sugar I'm gonna wait
a whole night that's right for you it
looks like cranberries of different
colors will you do the honors of mixing
this here we go so far I'm loving the
activity part of it fun you can do this
with a friend like us yeah we can do it
alone on the bus that was a rhyme okay
should we I'm not ready yet I'm late for
work
you go first okay
I won't look here face it's pretty good
when you make it properly like when you
don't leave will be ingredients yeah
leave all the ingredients sugar and put
so sure and everything sorry Starbucks I
like it I give that a yes because it's
customizable it's compact and it's Co
heavy it's like an activity to do with
friends this is a maybe and what I mean
is like it's a maybe cuz just needs to
be the right you know settings like if
it's a rainy day and I'm gonna like I'm
gonna go for that guy we have the
reduced got turkey bacon and was my
favorite so far
that I've had before so it's a wheat
English muffin egg white cheddar ooh and
disappointment at the same time yeah
okay let's one it's like a warm blanket
yeah but extra blankets this is an
obvious yes definitely oh my go to
yeah it's fine it's it's it just tastes
healthy I don't want to be shamed ever
again into eating this sandwich so I'm
always gonna pick the sounds I like more
therefore it's a no it's not disgusting
it's just not my sandwich of choice this
is the sausage egg and cheddar breakfast
sandwich alright this is like a classic
breakfast sandwich parody I love this
song
[Music]
so maybe like if there's a way to toast
in a little bit more what of advice if
you ever hung over one of these and a
full fat monster energy drink you you're
fine
doesn't matter how early you get this
stood up maybe this is a yes
and I'm gonna keep inching it
double-smoked bacon cheddar egg sandwich
okay oh it's on our kind of flat
croissants ready yep Starbucks coffee
why can you change coffee um I think
that smoke is what you're tasting is
coffee even this is a very flat
croissant so like texture is not the
fluffiest I would say the buttery
croissant is very delicious I like it
yeah probably one of the highest calorie
ones separate wouldn't pick it for me
this is a yes oh I think I'm going to go
with yes like it's a nice decadent one
maybe another good hangover one so this
is the sous vide egg white and red
pepper will pull my egg Cuffy you're
looking things you gotta say it's dense
it's very dead let's go with the densest
thing on the planet yeah hmm tiny home
look mm-hmm it's a little bit mushy if
your wines resetting you get like a
weird like party the Maury the Mormon
Maisie okay what about you yeah I'm a
maybe it's just like it like it just
wouldn't be the first thing yeah but I
wouldn't not eat it continuing with the
sous vide bites this is ham cheddar and
peppers
I'll take one and then I like that I
like you know more of the egg look on
the egg white look still very dense
it's very kind of kishi mm-hmm thank you
I like this the cheese is good I'm Dan
I'm a hundred I'm in I'm gonna come on
your soul and I'm in this a double yes
yes
continuing with the sous-vide eggs these
are the bacon in a career however you
want to say it it's very rich I don't
know what there's like butter in this
but then the bacon grease I like it but
I like the other better I like both
equally this one does feel a little
richer yes it's a maybe if I'm feeling
like really indulgent then yes but it
wouldn't be something if I just like
wanted it quick like a little just like
light like a light bite you need egg
again windblade chicken Cherie though
and tortillas but it sounds delish it
sounds yes I know my dear that makes
complete and the same makes me inspired
it I guess yes always turns like I told
you hmm I love this
he's like Tila Tequila yeah is that
cilantro there's a like a herb I'm
getting in here that it tastes really
good it's along Troy yes no I love it
like as with this is a chicken sausage
and bacon biscuit sandwich yes all right
cheers Cheers
[Music]
Gobert America mixer not sweet with that
same room right now
this is recently my go-to but only when
I'm and not an alcoholic
only when I'm hungover it is so rich
with the the biscuit and the sweetness
then I couldn't do it all the time this
would just be like when I really want to
treat myself so this is a yes oh yeah is
it - yeah bacon Gouda eggs doesn't
deserve the fanfare
let's do guy at the end is what we call
a ciabatta bread yeah this isn't
ciabatta
mmm oh dry mmm yeah I've never really
been much of a panini woman panini a
panini's pressed more cheese no just
that dusty hard bread oh you mean like
it's square yeah this is a no for me
it's not arable just it's just like it's
just there's been better I'm gonna give
it it's you know on a weekday if I was
in a rush and I didn't want to eat badly
for the weekday I might get this so
maybe I'm gonna give it like like a low
end maybe this is the spinach and feta
and egg white breakfast wraps it's a
wrap
I've had enough mm-hmm I like it I think
you're gonna be surprised
sun-dried tomatoes are in there you're
getting that doughnut so annoyed at
scheme I like it I'm very pleasantly
surprised I thought I'd hate it cuz it
looks dry and healthy yeah like my
ex-wife I would eat this for dinner I
would eat this for lunch
I'd eat it for breakfast it's like super
it tastes more like a sandwich to me
even though there's a Gannett I wouldn't
even for breakfast that sure you're
right I would
last time yes lunch time it's a
breakfast item but it's a lunch time
haha roasted ham swiss an egg breakfast
sandwich
[Music]
Chris on ok yes I am really full
oh those Swiss on that I'm gonna say
something right now it's my favorite
drop this on average on the sandwich
because it's so good it's gonna rip that
Swiss on there with the salt and then
the sweet buttery croissant yes
eivol in I'm doing this me it's a little
dry are we eating the same sandwich I'm
gonna give this one a maybe just based
on the fact it has croissan'wich I like
I like crossbones in general and it's
not bad it says maybe this is the spicy
chorizo Monterey Jack and egg sandwich
oh it's got like flecks of color in it
like herb like yes oh wait you ready for
this yeah loud whoa not for breakfast
for me but I like it I mean I like to
read oh it's too dry it just needs a
sauce with it you're right oh these
savages are relatively dry like there's
no salt which I get cuz it will make it
soggy really storing it so that makes it
smart and the cheese is hoping that but
this type of brother who's a little too
dry this is a maybe
almost no yeah I wanna maybe just
because I would put my maybe I would eat
that for lunch sometime this is more of
a lunchtime
it's a lunchtime maybe it's a lunchtime
maybe okay oh we did it it's happened
all the items I didn't know we could
make it but we did I'm so full of eggs
and bread we tasted some really great
stuff some you know like all right but
I'm impressed with the variety really
that they have I'm glad we learned all
of this because I didn't know they made
this many things and now if my favorite
item isn't available perhaps I wouldn't
be as angry about this basement we tried
them and now you should try them so and
let us know what your favorites are did
we insult your favorite Starbucks item
do you agree with us would you record
let us know in the comments
[Music]